what is going on with the show are you
done with the you've kind of intimated
that you're in we've done we're
scheduled for another season but I just
I can't see doing it anytime is that
because you're becoming a successful
movie actress as that the the game plan
no I'm just very tired
these Comedy Central not paying you
enough money to keep doing that you're
over it I'm I'm tired and it's a lot of
energy and I can't
are you pulling a Dave Chappelle are you
moving to Africa the people of Africa
want me there I'm not going for me there
they want me there but wait a second are
you saying that inside Amy Schumer very
successful for Comedy Central's
successful for you right everybody but
in a way it's a tremendously draining
kind of proposition every way in every
single way trying to take care of myself
oh you're saying my rib hurts so that's
the end of the show this season is the
last season it's not a negotiating
tactic it's not a negotiating tactic
this is it or is it like a Larry David
thing you'll take a couple of years off
and say now I'm gonna do it's a Larry
David thing yeah I try to live my life
like Larry yes I can't wait when there's
a candidate and I can come on SNL and I
look like them